tu sei bella routine 1 veste moggi
oggi un video un po particolare ho
deciso di farlo perché tanti di voi che
li seguono su instagram hanno notato che
ho tanti tanti occhiali da sole ma
quello che non sapete è che in realtà io
gli occhiali da sole le collezioni sono
piena di occhiali da sole
quindi ho deciso di aprire lo scatolone
dei miei occhiali da sole e farveli
vedere non li faccio vedere tutti perché
sono veramente tanti ma vi faccio vedere
insomma i miei preferiti
prima di iniziare a far rivedere i miei
occhiali vi ricordo se non l'avete
ancora fatto di iscrivervi al mio canale
e di cliccare sulla campanella vicino al
tasso d'iscrizione così non vi fermerete
nessuno dei miei prossimi video partiamo
subito con la prima categoria
la prima categoria non poteva non essere
il primo amore ebbene si questo occhiale
qua di versace rosa è stato il mio primo
occhiale firmato avrò avuto forse non so
14 o 15 anni non mi ricordo bene e avevo
fatto delle storie per averlo
incredibili me l'ha regalato
probabilmente il mio compleanno e
ovviamente era l'unico occhiale di
versace rosa quindi se dovevo scegliere
non scelgo colo rosa tra l'altro adesso
questa forma questo modello questo fiume
che vedete quando sfuma dall oscuro al
più chiaro è tornato stradi moda cioè
tutti i trappers hanno questi occhiali
ragazzi quindi prossimamente marina b
day e questa è una delle mie categorie
preferite perché quando ero un po più
piccolina avevo nei gusti un po più
eccentrici un po più tamarra e non solo
in fatto di vestiti ma anche e
soprattutto di occhiali anche perché
anni fa c'era degli occhiali veramente
super tamarri andavano stradi moda il
più tamarro della storia e questo è la
mascherina di dior non mi ricordo
esattamente l'anno in cui andava di moda
ma so solo che se ti giravi con questa
mascherina tu eri fico giustamente chi
non se li ricordo chi non era ancora
nato grama cosa essa porcheria ragazzi
che vedevo di andava di moda piaceva un
sacco era poco da figlia da da top d'oro
ma non me lo sono comprato io è stato un
regalo di seconda mano di mia cugina che
era molto più grande di me e ne aveva
due file oro e argento visto cosa di più
coloro ha detto bene quello argento
visto che ti piaceva in ateo regalo
questo compleanno in giro tipo il regalo
del secolo
e poi c'è il carrera bianco che è una
garanzia se vuoi essere tamarro perché
con tanti modelli di carrera non so se
va ancora di moda
però se succede gli altri colori sei
normale se tu ce l'hai bianco 6
ufficialmente tamarro e io di colore
siamo secondo voi ma non sapete la
storia che c'è dietro perché questo
occhiale qui non è mio il primo anno in
cui mi sono trasferita a milano era in
una casa con altri studenti
questo mio coinquilino che era molto
tamarro ha detto questo paio di occhiali
e a me piacevano un sacco quindi avevamo
fatto un change un cambio io non mi
ricordo
l'occhiale che gli ha dato in cambio se
hai fatto però molto contenta di questo
scambio e non l'ho mai messo però questo
occhiale vi è stata una moda passeggera
come se forse due volte dopo di che mi è
servito solo per riempire questa
categoria purtroppo come nel tag del
bikini non è che ci sono solo gli
occhiali belli che mi stanno bene che
non hanno problemi
infatti questa categoria è la categoria
dei larghi perché io gli ho comprati e
ios larga se totalmente quindi cosa
succede guarda un po
senza le mani si tolgono pazzesco l'ho
portato a stringere ovviamente si può
stringere ma comunque è troppo largo per
me voi dite ti sei svegliato tardi li
potevi provare quando per dzeko proprio
questi qui sono forse ancora più larghi
guardate addirittura si offrono le
stanghette karate che bella prima di
farvi vedere gli occhiali che
appartengono a questa categoria dovete
sapere che questo è carino li ho
comprati in un negozio vintage ma sono
degli occhiali di mia mamma
in primis c'è questo qui che io amo amo
l'omesso tantissimo
magari inesperienza non vi posterò
qualche foto con questo occhiale lo
mettiamo addirittura la sera per uscire
cioè con la gente che chiedeva che
problemi hai mai all yamaha voce non
credo proprio che non riuscivo a
staccarmi di dosso poi ci sono questi
qui di christian dior che sono molto
matrix reloaded
no sono ritornati mi dicono dalla
regione sobri eleganti poi ci sono
questi jil sander viola viola non è un
colore che amo ma in questo caso mi
piace molto da quella nota di intrigante
ametista parole a caso quale verrà anche
la moda è parole a caso perché tipo tu
cosa dici di questi occhiali
tartaruga tartarugati un po un po da
spolverare questo quindi polvere il
bello è quello degli occhiali vintage
che magari appunto perché li metti
perché sono tornati quelli che andavano
di moda e all istante anni settanta
ritornano nel 2020 la moda è ciclica la
moda è ritorno questa categoria è una
categoria che mi sta molto a cuore anche
perché sono tutti occhiali che hanno
fatto parte della mia vita e gli usati
tantissimo proprio perché gli usati
tantissimo non ce l'hanno fatta
questo occhiale questo chiave ha fatto
veramente la storia l'ho utilizzato
tantissimo e mi è piaciuto un sacco
quando si è sfasciato ma dedicherei un
momento speciale una parentesi a questi
due occhiali entrambi di marc jacobs
perché loro sono stati gli occhiali di
una delle estati più belle e divertenti
della mia vita
gallipoli 2011 durante l'estate 2011
appunto ho lavorato come pr ragazza
immagine e ballerina ho fatto insomma
una stagione estiva appunto in cui a
gallipoli è stato divertentissimo ma
soprattutto era sempre sotto il sole
quindi non ci crederete mai ma ero
abbronzata e quindi gli occhiali da sole
non sono stati fondamentali di più è la
cosa che vi giuro ragazzi mi fa venire
la pelle d'oca è che c'è ancora la
sabbia qua dentro sono completamente
rovinati perché è veramente le hanno
viste di ogni ma sono quelli a cui sono
più affezionata perché veramente mi
ricordano quel quell'estate di questo
qua è ancora leggermente a parte qualche
graffio sulla lente questo qua e proprio
scrostato sabbia
forse c'è ancora proprio all'acqua di
mare dentro
questa categoria è adoro l'ho chiamata i
2000 ma in realtà volevo chiamarla anche
paris in onore a paris hilton perché
sono proprio quegli occhiali che si
metteva sempre lei appunto negli anni
2000 tutti appunto molto tondeggianti
grossi map ovali questo in particolare
di jimmy choo ed è pazzesco
qua non so se si riesce a vedere sono un
anno la stanghetta pitonata e niente
sono veramente top e sono molto simili a
quest altro paio di occhiale che è
praticamente uguale ma ha le stanghette
bianche questo ancora più 2000 proprio
e poi c'è questo qui che è leggermente
più attuale perché un total black ma
sempre questa forma tondeggiante cosplay
di prada e l'omesso tantissimo credo che
l'estate fosse 2010 io direi solo una
parola a d'oro ma poi l'ho messo apposta
questo top perché sapevo che sarebbe
arrivato questo momento questo
abbinamento occhiale e coop veramente
pazzesco questi tra l'altro gli omessi
in questa categoria sobri ma sono in
realtà vintage di mia mamma quindi erano
in mezzo tra i due categorie visto che
la cia non ha già troppi ha detto la
metto alla società perché comunque la
fiorita prima di tutto
poi abbiamo questo qua specchiato
gianfranco ferrè anni ottanta favola
favola l'ho messo anche tantissimo e
tutti mi guardavano l'espulsione alieno
la parte gli scherzi al di là del fatto
che io amo loro sì ok sono impegnativi
però cioè se tu hai un amica lei dentro
si può specchiare
concluderei questo video con un oro nero
l'avete già visto in qualche tic toc
pubblicato di recente sobrio sobrio nel
senso che oltre a essere oro nero a una
catena che unisce le stanghette comunque
out e dalle carni
stop proprio top level con questo
fantastico occhiale io terminerei qui il
video spero che vi sia piaciuto mi
raccomando importantissimo fatemi sapere
con un commento qui sotto
quale categoria avete preferito oppure
quale occhiale da sole avete preferito
mi raccomando mettete un bel like se
volete un altro video
insomma di questa tipologia magari con
dei vestiti delle scarpe insomma fatemi
sapere cosa vi piacerebbe vedere e
soprattutto seguitemi su tutti gli altri
social infiniti instagram tik tok e
facebook
per vedere tutte le mie foto e il video
con questi fantastici occhiali con tutti
gli altri con quelli che non ci sono qua
nel video perché ce ne sono altri
ovviamente io vi mando un bacione e
copro d'oro ci vediamo al prossimo video
[Musica]